I will Jewish 2-butene with the sternum
second man dr. wood grifter danger -
damn were amazing comedy caught rotten
head nigga
Thank You solo solo has told you
positive karma horrify Palestine debacle
telling with umbrella commander Gustavo
demon is affordable fish casa que locura
mckenna they get the memo
we set up a makeshift studio so got
really good equipment a sound engineer
of course there's a generator so it's
noisy a bit like here but hopefully
hopefully we're gonna find some
musicians but we don't know how we're
gonna find
at the moment they really need windup
torches so one of our trucks will go
towards fundraising to get wind-up
torches int into the junk